[BEEPING]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER: As our customers
use cloud in bigger ways,
it's becoming
increasingly important
to simplify cloud management.
Deployment Manager is an
infrastructure deployment
service that
automates the creation
and management of Google
Cloud Platform resources.
Write flexible template
and configuration files
and use them to
create deployments
that have a variety of
Cloud Platform services,
such as Google Cloud
Storage, Google Compute
Engine, and Google Cloud SQL,
configured to work together.
This hands-on lab shows you
how to use Deployment Manager
to create a simple
configuration file,
use that file to
create a deployment,
and then view deployment
information on a manifest.
So what you'll do in this lab
is create a configuration,
deploy the
configuration, inspect
the running environment,
view the deployment manifest.
Deployment Manager allows
you to easily deploy
systems in a
variety of locations
and provides the control
needed to easily roll out
new services.
It also gives you
the flexibility
to deploy several versions
of your code simultaneously.
Next up on our quest
is Stackdriver--
Qwik Start.
This self-paced lab is a part
of the Deployment Manager
and baseline
infrastructure quests.